[BEEPS]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
LILIANA YU: Peter Bakkum, the
platform lead at Quizlet Inc.
said, "We believe GCP has
better core technology,
in particular, its networking
and disk technology."
Thanks, Peter.
We really appreciate that.
A huge component of why that may
be is Google's persistent disk.
Persistent disks are durable
network storage devices
that your instances can
access, like physical disks
in a desktop or a server.
The data on each persistent
disk is distributed
across several physical disks.
Compute Engine manages the
physical disks and the data
distribution to ensure
redundancy and optimize
performance for you.
Persistent disk offers
multi-reader capability.
With multi-reader mounting,
many virtual machines
can read data from a
single persistent disk
with no performance degradation.
Multi-reader mounting makes
sharing content a snap.
This lab will take you about
30 minutes to complete,
and you'll learn how to create
a virtual machine instance,
create a new persistent
disk, attach persistent disks
to a virtual machine
instance, format
and mount the persistent
disk, and automatically mount
the disk on restart.
Persistent disks are
located independently
from your virtual
machine instances.
So you can detach or
remove persistent disks
to keep your data even after
you delete your instances.
This is the fifth lab in
the GCP Essentials Quest.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Next up, Hello Node Kubernetes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]